[Música]
era uma vez uma menina ela tem sete anos
de idade e adora brincar ela gosta de
brincar de bola de boneca e de subir em
árvore
um certo dia ela resolveu fazer uma
brincadeira colocar o seu vestido
favorito no seu irmão mais novo certa do
sucesso da sua brincadeira ela convoca
todo mundo na sala para apresentar sua
arte
só que ela teve uma surpresa seu pai com
muita raiva e talvez sem pensar direito
rasga todo vestido aos gritos em 2005
é eu fui para curitiba foi quando eu fiz
faculdade e em 2009 eu me formei e
montei um coletivo de arte com mais
quatro amigos foi aí que eu aprendi a
fazer colagens aprendi sobre a arte de
rua e também sobre contra cultura o que
é contra a cultura é quando está todo
mundo indo para um lado você pára e
pensa e aí será que é por aí mesmo
na maioria das vezes vai pro outro lado
em 2011 e vim para são luís e montei
aqui um estúdio com design local e foi
quando eu inseri mais personagens
femininos na minha arte é na ocasião eu
fui convidada para fazer uma arte um
evento de capoeira e uma das premissas
do trabalho era usar a figura feminina
na capoeira e foi a primeira vez que
houve diferença nesses dois universos
eu nunca achei difícil ser mulher
então veio mural do epa é um evento que
celebra feminino
e eu lembro que na época é os
organizadores do evento é foi foram
falar com toda a vizinhança que a gente
ia fazer uma arte e todo mundo
empolgado nossa que legal vai ter gente
na rua mais cor né
só que quando eu terminei de fazer esse
mural
todo mundo queria pintar de branco e ea
gente fica pensando necomimi como falar
do feminino incomoda como no incomoda
como uma mulher empoderada incomoda
muitas pessoas se juntaram em frente
esse mural e contar as suas histórias e
foi a primeira vez que ouvi falar na
palavra feminismo de tão perto
em 2014 eu conheci uma mulher
o nome dela é sônia e e foi com ela que
eu aprendi a me alimentar direito e
também é não tomar remédio inclusive
anticoncepcional anticoncepcional é
remédio e não uma arma de poder feminino
e ele está sonhando ela falava o tempo
todo a em determinado lugar mulheres são
violentadas e isso é normal
não sei quantas mulheres são estupradas
por dia e aquilo me incomodava muito
porque a pessoa porque sua mulher ficar
falando sobre isso não quero ouvir falar
sobre isso eu ainda tenho medo da
palavra feminismo mas eu não tenho medo
de dizer que eu sou feminista porque
movimentos como esse eles em movimentos
como o feminismo como contra o racismo
ou contra a homofobia são de extrema
importância
inclusive se eles não existissem se o
feminismo não existisse eu não estaria
aqui conversando com vocês hoje
vocês acham que é difícil ser mulher
segundo a jornal o estado de são paulo
a cada 15 minutos uma mulher é
violentada no brasil
marias é meu trabalho mais recente e
esse trabalho é ele é composto por mais
ou menos dez imagens de mulheres com o
peito desnudo
é ele veio dono e veio também da ideia
de tirar o peito desse lugar de símbolo
sexual de tirar desse lugar de pudor
eu lembro que na época da faculdade eu
falava muito e eu falava que era um
absurdo esses artistas que ficavam no é
muito fácil ficar nu a mais ou menos um
ano e meio atrás
eu fiz uma viagem para os lençóis
maranhenses com duas amigas e foi quando
conheci lá e ela é performer e e eu
lembro que a gente estava andando pelas
dunas e quando e quando nós vimos ele
estava pelado lá ensinou pra gente como
é natural no como não é necessário ter
medo do novo
quando vou ter essa viagem um dia estava
no meu quintal cuidando das plantas e um
sol desses das 10 da manhã de são luís
né
e eu comecei a pensar e se eu fosse
homem será que eu ia tac fritando nesse
só de camiseta
eu demorei mais ou menos uma hora para
tirar a camiseta e dez minutos para
colocá-la de volta
além de conhecer pessoas incríveis
mulheres incríveis nesse trabalho marias
eu podia ouvir suas histórias e além das
histórias dessas pessoas dessas mulheres
que eu aprendi a conhecer mais
eu pude ver pessoas que também se viram
nesse trabalho
mulheres que se viram representados
nesse trabalho uma delas veio até mim e
falou o seguinte que ela se sente muito
bem com o seu corpo e que ela queria
muito ser uma maria também porque ela
tinha lamentado ela tinha tido um filho
e mesmo não tendo perdido com o peito
perfeito ela queria ser uma maria e aí
eu pergunto pra vocês o que é um ponto
perfeito
também houve relato de uma amiga que
disse que tinha colocado silicone muito
nova o que não suportava mais tem aquele
silicone
eu levei 30 anos para entender como é
difícil ser mulher é esse foi o momento
que maria foi pra rua e foram três dias
de vocês de trabalho e muitos amigos
ajudaram a fazer esse mural foi pro o
dss engajada de arte e eu lembro que eu
terminei a noite e no dia seguinte eu
fui correndo para lá para tirar foto
eu sabia que alguma coisa podia
acontecer na áea quando passei por lá à
noite ainda eu vi que tinha acontecido
alguma coisa neste mural e quando
cheguei em casa tinha um monte de
mensagens das pessoas falando que tinha
acontecido uma violência naquele moral e
aí eu vi essa palavra ustra ulstra vive
vocês sabem quem foi outra
os ultra fan general da época da
ditadura é brasileira
na ditadura militar brasileira que
torturou centenas de pessoas muitas
delas mulheres e que a gente não sabe
mas nem notícia
nesse mesmo dia é diversas pessoas se
reuniram em frente esse mural e essa
palavra horrorosa se tornou mostra as
tetas e vive
foram 48 horas de batuque de tumor de de
muito protesto e quando vários nomes de
mulheres foram lembrados neste mural
várias mulheres inclusive que foram
mortas pela violência
e essa foto eu acho ela muito linda
porque ela representa muito
o marias ele representa muito que maria
se tornou o movimento de igualdade de
direitos
hoje está todo mundo igual aí e até se
vocês repararem a maioria das pessoas
nessa foto são homens
o que é muito lindo porque mostra que
várias pessoas se juntaram independentes
de homem mulher para uma mesma causa o
fim da violência contra a mulher
o machismo existe e mulheres também são
machistas é um dias depois recebi uma
mensagem na verdade foi uma publicação
nas redes sociais onde uma mulher dizia
que foi infeliz
a idéia de fazer um mural ali em frente
a um colégio e aí eu fiquei pensando
será que ela sabe que foi o único lugar
que eu conseguir liberação para fazer
esse mural que foi a única pessoa que
abriu para que a gente fizesse esse
mural ali e que essa discussão fosse
colocado neste mural e aí eu pensei mais
um pouco e que bom que esse mural tava
ali em frente ao colégio e foi o que eu
disse pra ela porque quem sabe a
discussão poderia ser ampliada
tanto para homem para os pais para as
mulheres e para as crianças professores
e aí quem sabe a gente poderia formar
cidadãos um pouquinho diferente
a liberdade é negociável
histórias como eu contei lá no começo
elas continuam acontecendo
só que hoje eu vejo pais que não tem
medo de colocar um vestido e mostrar
para o filho que tudo bem colocar um
vestido não existe certo ou errado nisso
hoje eu acredito no movimento do
respeito eu vou ler umas palavras da ema
ótimo
como podemos mudar o mundo quando só
metade dele é convidado ou se sente bem
vindo para participar da conversa
tanto o homem quanto mulher devem se
sentir livres para serem sensíveis tanto
homens quanto mulheres devem se sentir
livres para serem fortes
está na hora de nos olharmos para as
questões de gênero em um aspecto maior
ao invés de duas possibilidades opostas
senão eu quem se não agora quando
e se você ainda dei a palavra feminismo
não é a palavra que importa é a ideia ea
ambição que ela carrega obrigado